How you doing, man? Yo, what's up?
What's up? What's up? What's up? Yeah.
Uh, what's what proof do you need for
Islam? I just need to see where
Muhammad's mentioned in the NGO cuz the
Quran says he is. Yeah, he's actually
mentioned all over there. Okay. What
verse you got? But the thing is, the
thing is that the refers to what Jesus
was given. Okay. So, even if you don't
find him in the New Testament, that
doesn't disregard what the Quran says.
Is the New Testament the angel? Well,
what's the general understanding of
injil? The angel is the New Testament.
That's what I've that's what I've heard.
But no, the angel is not Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John. The angel is given to
Jesus. Was Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John
given to Jesus? All right. Yeah. Yeah.
So, what So, I don't believe that Jesus
was walking around with with anything.
What What is your view? So my view is
obviously the Quran says that he was
given the and you know um many schools
of thought will say different things you
know many sects preferably I'm from the
the Shia sect so I have some different
beliefs from what my scholars say okay
so my scholars believe
in which is not like distortion of the
Quran but distortion of its meaning
right right so what this mean yeah so
what this means is that people like to
play around with the meanings, right?
They misinterpret it or they might
distort meanings and stuff. I get you.
Yeah. Yeah. So, this wouldn't be, you
know, heretic. It would actually be a
fact cuz you see this every single day.
Yeah. You see it all the time. Exactly.
So, that's why I'd say that this can be
interpreted in so many ways. Like this
is ambiguous. When the Quran says that
Jesus was given a book, like what could
this mean, you know? Okay. So, um, it's
is it it's unclear if Jesus was walking
around with an actual book? Uh, it's
unclear because it says that the prophet
confirms it. So, but he never even
actually got to see it. So, how do you
how do you know he never got to see it?
Uh, because Well, well, did he even open
the book before? Is there a single
hadith of that? Um there's not
necessarily a hadith of him opening the
book, but there's a hadith that where he
says that uh the the angel is with the
Christians. Like he says it's with them
like what which hadith? And that's Johny
2653. Yeah, that that's a Sunni hadith.
That's true. I'm I'm more familiar with
the Sunni sources, not necess not really
the Shia sources. So I wouldn't know if
there's anything in the Shia sources
about it. Yeah. Yeah. So the Shia
sources actually say something that's
like kind of like that but it's a little
bit different. So Shia sources say that
the meaning of in was his revelation not
necessarily a physical book that there
we go. All right. So that would mean
that Jesus was walking around orally
preaching the or the gospel, right? But
not necessarily walking around pre
preaching out of a book with pages and
you know like that. Okay. So, however,
eventually the angil this his message
did get written down. The Quran says
that it was written and that the
Christians have it. Which hadith or
which verse? It's actually a verse. So,
it's uh it's in the Quran on chapter 7
verse 157. And and what does it say? It
says those who find who those who follow
the unlettered prophet whom they find
written in the Torah and the gospel and
the angel with them. Yeah, but that's
still ambiguous though. That can mean
many things. No, it can. It's very
clear. It says that the angel and Torah
is written down and it's with the
Christians and that you can find
Muhammad written in there or like the
unleted prophet, you can find his
description written in there. Yeah. As I
said again, um the description of the
prophets is found in the the New
Testament, but we wouldn't consider that
the angel because really Okay. Well,
hold on. Pause that. Pause that cuz
that's interesting. So, the New
Testament is not the angel. It's not the
revelation of Jesus. However, you still
can find prophecy, revelation from God
in the New Testament. Well, I wouldn't
say that like there's obviously Muslim
da people who who give verses in the
Bible that seem to appear like
descriptions of the prophet, but you
know, you can't always be 100%, right?
Well, you could be 100% that it's not
him. I'll tell you that. Yeah. So, like
there's there's obviously verses that
could fit his description. You know,
there's not a single one in the New
Testament that could fit Muhammad's
description. I mean, even if there is
not a single one, let's just say there
was zero. None. Well, that wouldn't go
ahead. I'm sorry. That would not that
would not disregard what the Quran's
saying. Well, that if the if the New
Testament's not the fine. So, that's
that's why I'm asking I didn't ask about
the New Testament. I asked about the
NGO. I asked where is Muhammad in the
NGO? Where can I find him in the NGO?
Oh, well, the thing is you can't find.
How do you know? Well, because that's
just what the belief of my scholars is.
Okay. So, if I'm just if I'm a I mean,
I'm on the outside looking in, bro. I'm
not a Muslim and and I'm reading the
Quran. I'm a Christian reading the
Quran. And I'm reading verses that talk
about the gospel, that talk about Jesus,
that talk about the previous prophets.
And I come across this verse that
fascinates me. It says that Jesus
mentions Muhammad mentions Ahmed to come
after him. And it says that we can I can
find Muhammad or the unlettered prophet
mentioned in the gospel. So if I came to
you and I'm like, "Hey, you know what?
I'm a Christian. This verse right here
says I can find Muhammad in the gospel.
This is interesting to me. Where can I
find it? And where can I find him in the
gospel?" You'll say, "Well, you you
don't have the gospel. We can't find
him." That's what you'll tell me. Yeah.
Let me just elaborate on that. So what I
mean is that even if we don't have um
the gospel, it wouldn't affect us. The
reason why is because when the Quran
says that we'll find him in the gospel,
the gospel we we wouldn't our scholars
necessarily don't interpret it interpret
this as a as a literal physical book.
You know, you know what I mean? Well,
the Quran does the Quran says it's a
literal physical book eventually. Yeah.
When we say written down in the gospel,
why would it make sense for God to tell
us that it's written down in the gospel
if we don't have the gospel? Well, that
but Well, that's the thing. It says they
have it. See, you're presuming we you're
presuming we don't have the gospel. The
Quran says we do.
7th century Arabia, they had the words
of God. They had the gospel, right?
Well, I wouldn't say the gospel is the
literal is a literal book, like a
physical book. Brother, again, let's
let's Do you believe your Quran? Do I
believe in the Quran? Well, I believe in
the Quran, but I don't always believe
what's right in front of me. Like, you
need to go deeper into Do you believe in
the Quran, man? I believe in the Quran,
but I also have my own interpretation
with as well scholar. Do you love the
Quran? Do I love the Quran? Yeah. Of
course, I love the words of God. So, if
the words of God say something, would
you say anything otherwise? If the words
of God plainly say something and I'm
going to wrongfully assume what it
means? Yeah. But would you would you
ever if the word of God says something,
would you say otherwise? If I know the
full meaning of what it's saying? Of
course. If it says plainly, the Injil is
written down. Would you come and say,
"Well, no, the Injil wasn't written
down." Oh, written down in what sense?
I can't do this. Wait, wait, relax.